first time I interview he comes in and
he's it's an it's an Iowa we're in an
airplane hangar in Des Moines he's
coming it's the first time he's gonna go
to the Iowa State Fair man of the people
and he comes in and he gets off airplane
hangar and he's wearing his make America
great hat yeah and then he finds out
that were inside taping this interview
so he takes the hat off and he is just
not happy and his hair and he said I'm
sitting there going and he's like no I
want to wear the hat and I'm like you
can't wear your hat this is I'm sickened
this is Meet the Press right have this
guy wearing a hat right inside so he
takes it off he says all right all right
how's my hair look can I what you look
like Donald Trump yeah way nobody's
gonna mistaken you for oh my god it's
Conan's hair tonight right right you
know have you okay with everything he's
sitting there futzing and I said you
know look you get it look you know I'm
look at my hair I'm like you know thin
thinned out and everything you said your
hair's great you just need a you just
need to take a little pill take a pill
take propecia yeah and I sit there and
say well all right you know I don't
wanna do that it has that side effect
and he said I don't do worry about that
what yeah he says I don't have to worry
about that side effect have you ever had
propecia what is it what does it do when
it has that side effect what do you want
me to say do you not to say more than
you've already said we're not a bunch of
pharmacy I know what he speaks yeah side
effect is well it's it's known to be a
boner-killer
so and he said that's not a problem
anymore no and it's not a problem for
him
so virile oh I see so he meant that he
wasn't doing anything no when someone
says to me my penis doesn't work put it
in a pot anymore that's where I go you
go that far
okay you didn't go that far there was a
little subtlety to it let's talk about
whether that antidote worked well let's
talk about I love it listen you see you
got to bring your pharmacologist
you